hello and thank you all for subscribing
watching and your patience because last
month in my Captain America the Winter
Soldier review I said hey let's do a Q&A
we're going to celebrate half a million
subscribers and it's been a month since
then but I've looked them over and I to
be honest with you won't get to all of
the questions or thousands of questions
on that video but I picked the ones that
I thought were the best questions and
the ones that people were given a lot of
thumbs up to and the ones that people
asked multiple times so hopefully this
encompasses all you guys wanted to know
about me and yes I am surrounded by my
favorite things in life The Killing Joke
Joker right over here and the last five
minutes of the amazing spider-man 2 over
there and I'm gonna divide this into two
videos actually because when videos
ramble on for too long it just freaks me
out so all right two videos it is right
let's start this Q&A let's get to know
each other a little bit more what's the
strangest film you've seen that's a
really good question cuz I've seen some
really weird [ __ ] but I'm weird as in I
mean comedies can be weird drama can be
weird but the weirdest movie I'd say
there's got to be Freddy got fingered
with Tom Green I walked out of that
movie going holy [ __ ] I know I think I'm
dumber I think I'm actually dumber the
movie knows it's at the end this guy's
holding a sign saying wins this [ __ ]
movie can and or something like that so
the movie knows it's dumb but it's
actually dumb it doesn't succeed in
making fun of the fact that it's dumb
it's just really really stupid
what's the creepiest moment in movies
games TV for you I don't know if this is
the creepiest for movies but a sinister
was up there for me you know that movie
creeped me out there's something about
the fact that when he found out that
dude was in all the footage and I would
the watchers us the viewers we saw him
but we didn't know we saw him that
creeps me out when something kind of
just slips under my radar and he's in
plain sight and I didn't see him that
that creeps me out game's got to be
Resident Evil when the dog bust through
the window freaked me out as a kid um TV
is usually not that creepy for me how
was your high school experience 9th
grade I was average 10th grade I skipped
school so much it baffles me I was like
I'm gonna fail I'm gonna fail 10th grade
in fact after 10th grade if I passed
every class it'd be two full credits shy
of graduating so I went to summer school
junior year in senior year I crack down
busted my ass and graduated on time with
all my credits it actually kind of
taught
me how to focus myself in terms of
personal relationship was a nerd how do
you think it went it was terrible how
many of these have you done with no
pants on I assume you meet videos so - I
think it was - every video that I have
not had pants on in I have said I don't
have pants on in and so I think that's -
that's me I'm honest to a fault that's
just how I roll
q have you ever gotten recognized at the
movie theater yeah I've been recognized
in movie theaters and the malls that's
always fun I was like meeting fans but
one in particular it was at World's End
I got recognized by a group of fans who
like Jimmy John's can I sit next to you
in the movie I was like sure so he sat
next to me in the movie and they they
got to watch a movie with me I guess but
just funny because I don't talk in
movies so they just really got to watch
a movie and I could have been anybody or
not there at all it would have made no
difference to them but apparently it did
so that was always fun that was cool
they were cool people how do you deal
with negative criticisms of your reviews
negative criticisms you don't you just
go okay they didn't like me or they
don't like it or just being trolls and
whatever you move on have you ever
drastically changed your opinion about a
movie / TV series after taking a second
look kind of not like so drastically
where it goes from positive to negative
or negative to positive Fi if I give you
a movie a positive review it's still
positive when I think about it or I
watch it a second time at five say it's
a negative review it's still negative it
might fluctuate a little bit but it's
always you it's good you should watch it
or it's not and you shouldn't and that
stays consistent one of them's like 21
Jump Street is a good example I said
it's a good time to alcohol required
it's actually I would say buy it on
blu-ray now you know so it's like that
little it goes a tick up or a tick down
but never crosses the oh I loved it
actually it sucks it's never did not
like that question why do you always hit
me in the face after a video why you do
this Jeremy I was actually going to
breeze right over this one it's actually
there's a story to it I'm you know my
old videos I used to end the video with
me going I [ __ ] around and then when
I swish it from movie man 1 9 1 - Jeremy
Jones I was like alright what would I
change now and so I got rid of the I
ain't [ __ ] around thing simply
because I described it to someone like
if I have to scream I am [ __ ] around
at the end of every video it's it's
almost like that person that has to say
something so much you're like do you not
believe it so I'd rather just show
people I'm not [ __ ] around by being
honest
so I got rid of that I was like well I
need something at the end so in the
meantime I'll just you know punch the
screen and then I'll think of something
and then it just kind of became a thing
and it became iconic and so I was like I
can't change it now that's why I punch
you in the face what novels do you want
to see adapted into film that's a really
good question I haven't read it but I
heard the Deaf gate cycle is just one of
the greatest things ever so I'd like to
see that get adapted in terms of graphic
novel I think death of the family in the
DC new 52 that's a you're a joker fan
you need to watch the read rather death
the family death of the families blew my
mind a couple times I was like I feel
ill like I feel bad for loving the Joker
as much as I do
what's your day job I'm always curious
about a youtubers day job and whether
their co-workers have seen their Channel
actually my day job is this I do YouTube
videos I used to age alright if you want
the story of my work history I worked at
a movie theater as a projectionist then
I quit that and I became a retail
manager
and I suck at it I realized to be a
retail manager at least in this company
you had to be a dick and I just wasn't a
dick so I quit that I went back to being
a projection is that a different company
and I liked that cover the first company
I hated to death and the second company
I really liked there was a smaller
company so they were you know human and
I was a projection is there and that's
actually how I saw the movies early and
everyone there the managers the CEO they
were all like I liked your channel and I
want it to grow I know eventually you'll
quit but we love you and we want to see
you succeed and so they're still very
cool and I and I'm on good terms with
them and I one day went to them and I
was like I don't need to work here
anymore um and that's that so we're all
cool and they're cool and so that was my
job mainly projection is don't ever be a
retail manager because you'll hate
yourself what computer games do you
think would make great movies I'm sure
whatever game gets put into movie form
it's going to be completely ruined but I
would like to see a really good now I'd
like to see a great Metal Gear Solid
movie or Metal Gear movie just any
section of that world I'd like to see
snake go up against big boss or Solid
Snake go up against liquid snake I'd
like to see a Metal Gear Solid movie
or a Medicare movie do you smoke just
say either yes or no no will you ever do
gaming videos I imagine you mean like
well I play the game and you can see
what I'm doing and we just go through
the game and I do commentary while I'm
doing it um I'm not sure because if you
remember about December January YouTube
was on this crazy gaming channel witch
hunt and that looks like it went away I
don't know if it's completely gone now
so um I I might I'm not removing the
possibility I'll just have to see where
it goes I'd like to I need to see what
feels safe enough to do so that we'll
see why do you think watching movies
benefits people and think that if you
have a shitty aspect of life that you
just don't like and you want to escape
movies are a great escape that's why in
the Great Depression people went to the
movie theaters that's what the movie the
movie business didn't actually suffer as
much as the rest of the world because it
was a great escape for people so it can
but it also can't so it's just relative
it depends on the person it depends on
the movie do you know who Roger Ebert is
and if so do you consider an
inspirational at all this I feel like I
need to tread lightly because I don't
want to speak ill of the dead Roger
Ebert was you know this very
revolutionary film critic you know you
took one of the bigger use of first like
I feel like he was the first celebrity
film critic he's passed on now did I
consider him inspirational I watched his
show when it was Siskel and Ebert and
then Ebert and Roeper but what I noticed
is I didn't agree with them a lot of the
times at all and I was like why don't I
agree with movie critics and so at a
point when I started doing this as a
hobby it became a thing and then I was
like I feel like I might be able bear
with me on this to be that that reviewer
I don't like the word critic but I guess
technically is what i am that critic
that people can be like that's the one
because I'm a human being and I'm normal
and I I relate to that guy I never
really had that
so I I'd like to hope that I bring that
to other people in that Roger Ebert
inspired me as much as Michael Bay did
to do my videos but no I don't find a
kindred spirit in him if that's what
you're asking I like the guy and sure
a swell fellow but not the way you would
want me to think he is I'm not good
that's why I didn't do a video about his
death I'm not like Roger Ebert you were
so inspirational me because he really
wasn't Jeremy Jones I'm also a huge
movie geek and I've thought about
starting a blog and vlog channel any
tips on getting started this is going to
sound really generic but my tips would
be have fun with it
try not to make it your job but like do
it for a hobby don't do it because
you're like I want to get income and
quit my job and that'll be that do it
because you feel it's fun so sometimes
you're going to see something and be
like I should talk about that but yeah I
might hold back because I want to relax
today so if you burn yourself out it's
going to be competitive you want to get
your information up first I get that but
if you do it too much for too long
without rest and it's going to feel like
a job and you're going to burn yourself
out and you're not going to do it
anymore when you're doing it if you do
it the audio or audio and video whatever
you make think to yourself if I wasn't
in it would I watch this or listen to it
if the answer is yes he probably did
something right so keep doing that if
you were threatened at gunpoint and
given a choice between watching Birdemic
Batman and Robin the last airbender
after earth or Dragonball Evolution
which would you pick sorry dying is not
an option well that's kind of dick
because dying is always an option in
things like that but if I had to pick
one I would pick Batman and Robin
because it's it's at least so cheesy and
terribly bad like the thing killed a
complete franchise and all the
characters in it but there's some morbid
piece of enjoyment out of the fact that
it's so terrible it's kind of funny
here's a question for you Jeremy since
most of your views watch your videos on
mobile devices you ever think where
someone is watching your videos that
would be viewer sir and if you haven't
watched a youtube video while taking a
[ __ ] you haven't lived what's the best
and worst movie you have ever seen Plus
congrats on 500,000 subs
well thank you very much the best and
worst well the bottom you know my
favorite movies and my favorite movies
are Lord of the Rings um I would if I
had to pick a single movie though I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm going to go
outside Lord of the Rings for a second
Empire Strikes Back it's one of those
movies that just gets better than
i watch it and the older I get the that
that is counted as one of the best it's
hard to pick a best [ __ ] Lord of the
Rings trilogy um worse probably
Battlefield Earth which is a funny story
my uncle was coming at a gladiator and
my brother and I were going to watch a
Battlefield Earth in the movie theater
we're like John come on
sneak in with us so he went from
gladiator straight into Battlefield
Earth I don't think he's forgiven me
ever
do you have one particular movie that
really cemented your passion for films
it's fun I had to really think about
this one what's the earliest movie that
I walked out of going that wasn't a
movie that was an experience that was
Church um the the one I can think of up
top of my head after thinking about it a
long time which actually isn't the top
of my head
moments like that are why I do jump cuts
in case you're wondering um Jurassic
Park I saw Jurassic Park and I was like
holy [ __ ] because I was a kid I love
dinosaurs and they were real now and so
I watched Jurassic Park a few times in
the movie theater I just remember had
the coolest sound the t-rex when he
roared blew my teeth out I I have no
words to describe the first time I saw a
Jurassic Park I just remember I loved
everything about it and collected all
the McDonald's cups what was it like
meeting Nathan Fillion I was so nervous
and I'm sure I came across to him as
boring I was probably forgettable he was
like whatever this [ __ ] is one in a
million diddy 'it's like him interview
me all the time he's nothing special
because I had to contain my fanboy ISM I
was like all right don't worry your
Firefly shirt and go there and be a
professional I had to my friend who was
there operating the cameras in the sound
equipment I was like hey I don't want to
meet Nathan Fillion and Clark Gregg he
was like yeah um he I was like can you
drive because I really need to get into
it like mode and think about the
questions and write them down so you can
see the interview I drink a lot of that
water in front of me because I'm [ __ ]
nervous it was really cool though he's
an awesome guy like it's cool to see
people that are your entertainment icons
and idols or whatever and when they're
good human beings you feel at each are
like ah you're cool alright now I can
sleep better at night what is your
favorite game of all time alright I
would say there's a lot out there that I
like but there's only one that I've
inked my body with so here is your
answer and if you don't know what it is
don't worry I'll tell you but but I'm
gonna flex also because I need
to make it look impressive but there it
is right there
that's legacy of kain and a huge legacy
cane Fanta still am a huge legacy Akane
fan Amy Hennig took the reins of that
story and she's the one who ended up
really doing taking the reigns of
Uncharted she created Uncharted and she
is a really good storyteller and all the
dialogue in her games or that it's just
well-written Legacy Kane ultimately is a
vampire story when vampires were still
badass they weren't you know they're to
make chicks the horny I need to put this
on cuz need to look cool again
but yeah legacy Akane it's it's one of
the greats and I'd like to see a
resolution to that sty like to see it
wrap up because there's no real ending
so even if they do it in novel form I'd
like to see an end to legacy of kain one
day can you review more video games I'd
like to but here's the thing with video
games I'm a one-man show here I just did
just me in my camera and my sound things
and in my lights and my editing and I do
it all so if I was to review a game it'd
be me doing it and movies you're in and
out two hours done games they take a
long time to do so
when I'm playing a game it locks me up
doing that for a few days I'm not one of
the people who can fly through a game in
a day so it I'd like to do more games
but it is just noticeably more time
consuming but yes if you could reboot an
old show or movie from your childhood
even if it's already been rebooted what
would it be funny thing about that my
answer to that would be Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers which I guess they're
turning into a movie the way I see it I
told my friend I was like dude that that
could be x-men meets Pacific Rim how is
that not awesome if it's done well I
mean the first one you have them all
come together and be great in this next
one you can do the Green Ranger saga if
it's you know movies we're talking that
could be really cool I'd like to see
that happen now that it's happening I'd
like to see how they do it so that are a
proper Ninja Turtles what editing
software do you use for your intro I
didn't make my intro my intro is
actually made by a fan of mine all of my
intros have been made by fans of mine
for editing though for editing my videos
it's adobe premiere pro cs5 you guys
were wondering do you want to be a
reviewer indefinitely or is this more of
a temporary hobby for you I got to
quit my job because I made enough on
YouTube to talk about movie something I
did anyway with my friends I still do
with my friends so really yeah it's a
hobby that I do for fun I have no reason
to want to give that up now what's your
favorite porn site I like to see how
creative I can get with Google Images a
question about your trademark the red
gradient background which is sometimes
blue rarely how did you come up with
this idea is there any reason behind it
winky face died just semi red seemed a
thing to do at first I wanted to roast
shitty movies so I was like red it's
angry and you know it's there and it's
just in your face just makes you angry
or when you see it so I did it and then
it just kind of became a staple and when
I reviewed trailers I wanted it to look
different so usually when I'm reviewing
movie trailers or talking about
something moving news related that isn't
a movie or game review it'll be it'll be
blue so you can differentiate you know
I'm a color scheme kind of person I
guess but if it's a movie review red red
because I wanted it to look angry now I
don't necessarily want it to look angry
but it's just iconic it's my thing I've
been doing it for a few years now why
change it if it works why change it I
like the red Jeremy do you have a
favorite theme song from a movie um my
favorite I shoot that stuff but the
Jurassic Park theme song is pretty up
there
Star Wars is probably the most iconic of
all time but Jurassic Park is very good
we're talking words vocals circle of
life from The Lion King how is the Lion
King not one of the coolest movies ever
let my videos Jeremy and congrats on
500k I have to ask do you own just one
suit or do you have a whole bunch of
them lying around I have a few of them
they're not just lying around I have a
couple of like nice suits I was like I
want nice suit so I wore those at PAX so
if you saw anything relating to me in
packs of 2013 and wear my nice suits in
some of those the Blazers I have a
couple of those just wear them for
videos or if I'm just feeling like we're
in the Blazer I like dressing nice it's
just a thing with me how did you come up
with your rating system well people are
asking me for a rating system I usually
don't like ratings because I'm like
ratings to me or a cheat sheet it's like
you give this whole review and then in
the end people need you to rate it for
them which ultimately always told me
they didn't listen
the review like if you're listening to
some to the review you would know if the
person likes it or hates it but so I was
like well if I'm gonna do a rating
system it's going to be you know
sentence based so kind of sarcastic you
know so it's a one sentence thing where
you know where I'm coming from which is
kind of a cheap cop-out but I just
wanted to make it fun and interesting so
it's like my rating system is a writing
system that I can get behind so I just
kind of made it sarcastically like
here's your writing system and so again
people responded well to it and they
seem to like it some people have asked
for a numerical rating system in which
case now what is a movie you think
everyone should watch [ __ ] that's a lion
king like I said what's your favorite
color purple like the royal purple like
Joker purple yeah that dude's purple is
pretty good purple it's pretty
lavenderish though but I like dark
purple what's the best joke you've ever
heard baby seal walks into a club do can
you talk without moving your hands and
your arms try I think you will fail how
boring is that what if I did this what
if i sat here like this and talked like
this all the time and it would know I
moved my head is that bad kind of what
if I did this how statuesque how boring
is this [ __ ] in the competitive world of
YouTube you think I'm not going to talk
how I talk I actually talk with my hands
I talk to people I talk like this [ __ ] a
lot of good people are like I wish you
had more energy sarcastically but that's
just how I am I talk with my hands
deal with it where did the term awesome
tacular and all the other vocab from
your rating system come from I really
don't know how it came up with awesome
tacular I took awesome and spectacular
and fused him together ie the rest of my
writing that just came up with because
it would I buy it on blu-ray yes it's a
good time yes how good I kind of got to
be drunk for it all right well it's a
good time if you're drunk what's the
opposite of that well good timing for
silver and no alcohol required so I mean
it's I just came up with it because it
just seemed thing to do that's how I see
the world but um awesome tequila I know
that in my Zombieland review I said the
zombie tacular land of zombies guns and
awesome somehow I feel like that's the
prelude awesome tacular what do you
think is the most overrated movie - that
I can think of this is probably gonna
cost me a few people to go look it I'm
out this guy's a dick but um two movies
that I watched and I was like I don't
get it I don't get the hype is The Hurt
Locker
I was like big deal he disarms bombs in
Afghanistan's very cool is this a chick
who did Point Break because she was more
interesting when she did Point Break
even though that's terrible acting but
um other than that there will be blood I
love Daniel day-lewis I loved him in it
he's a good actor but that movie bored
me shitless the soundtrack is locusts
and air-raid sirens I don't go get it
either I don't care it's no it's boring
pancakes or waffles pancakes have you
ever seen Pulp Fiction have you ever
seen my review of poll fiction how much
money do you spend on a monthly basis to
see all these movies no usually none
usually I can catch them at the movie
theater I worked at in which I can see
them I can screen them there because
it's like I still work there but I don't
see what is it's a gray area thing but
they're very cool to me their data i
screen them in Seattle at the screening
so usually nothing some some of them I
miss and I'll have to go track it down
and spend 15 bucks every couple months
so 15 bucks every couple months don't
hate me what made you want to grab a
camera film yourself reviewing a movie
and post it on YouTube and did you think
it would go anywhere I just like talking
about movies and so I saw transformers 2
and I was like I didn't like that I
think I should talk about that and just
ranted on camera about it and then one
thing led to another people like that
and they like the next one that like the
next one just went on from there I
thought it would go places I didn't
think it would go the places it's gone
this fast
that makes sense Marvel or DC Marvel for
the movies DC for the comics it seems
that you gained a lot of subscribers and
popularity from your Mass Effect review
way back when looking back now is there
anything you would have done differently
or changed in that review I believe
you're talking about the Mass Effect 3
ending and why we hate it video funny
you should say that because yes there is
a part I it's tough for me to watch that
video because there's one part if I can
just reach in there and pull it out I
would and it's when I say EA you owe us
a new ending give us another ending just
something about the way I said you owe
us sounds like I'm some entitled
[ __ ] sitting in his mom's basement
but it's what it looks like it's like
I'm on camera safely behind my keyboard
going you OS this it sounds very
entitled I don't like how it sounds if I
could take that part out I would
um I can't toys roll with it and I mean
the videos fine as is if it's like 98
percent great cool it's 98 percent is
still awesome but that is definitely the
part I would take out everything else I
would keep everything else is great in
that video how did you get started with
YouTube and what made you decide that
this would work for your career Thanks
hope you answer in terms of the career
part what would make it work for a
career I just financially when you make
enough to replace the job you have you
just kind of do that and there is the
concept that that's a very fickle thing
to be financially dependent on but
really there is no such thing as job
security I have worked retail management
I've worked in movie theaters I that's
the is the basis of my work experience I
worked at one of those I forgot about
this worked at a cellphone company I was
one of those douche bags in the mall
that would try to get you by plan I
sucked at that job too and they were
gonna can me because I don't upsell old
ladies plans I don't need but really
what is job security doesn't exist
funny thing this is a true story when I
went into the movie theater and said hey
I don't need this job anymore they asked
the same question like what if YouTube
goes away what if you don't make money
about that on that anymore
and then one of the movie theaters in
that company ended up quitting or not
quitting but ended up getting shut down
and so I was just kind of like go to
them until then they had job security
you know you can't so um it's as secure
as anything I suppose anyone can get
canned I've known people who have gotten
fired who were fine workers layoffs
whatever so it works for me how is
becoming a movie reviewer impacted your
regular movie experience you ever go to
a movie just to see a movie do you think
you're more critical of movies now I
still have that part of my brain that
lets me enjoy movies for the sake of
enjoying them but you definitely are
more critical of them you've noticed
things and you notice like wait that
doesn't make sense why do you say that
why wouldn't he it's kind of a bummer
but it's real
have you ever considered moving to
California to try to physically bring
yourself a little closer to filmmaking
funny thing I actually moved to
California I was there I swear to God
for one month I moved down there I got
an apartment and I looked around I was
like this place is terrible it's smoggy
the people are [ __ ] I don't know why I
left everyone I care about up in
Washington screw this noise I am one of
those people I can see down the road and
go alright this is either going to work
out this way or that way and I
like I can either move back now and just
bite the bullet and the fact that I lost
this money that it takes to move down to
California or I can try to stick it out
end up moving back anyway and pay about
one year's worth of rent in Los Angeles
California which sucks ass I'd be so
expensive so I thought I'll just bite
the bullet and move back now no and this
again we live in this technological
Wonderland of the internet so there's no
real need for me to be in Hollywood to
do movie reviews and if I want it to be
closer to filmmaking if I wanted to be a
filmmaker then I'll reassess it but for
right now now Washington's read it works
for me why are your first few reviews
the ones very difficult to find very
different in tone than your current much
more enjoyable reviews well first of all
I'm glad you enjoy reviews secondly like
I said I wanted to really dig into
movies and you roast them and tear them
up if they were [ __ ]
but it's so negative and you have so
much negative energy you're putting out
there and I was always thinking about
like what's the next video I'm gonna do
how I'm gonna say it what am I gonna be
like how am I gonna tear it apart and
it's just perpetual negativity all the
time and I found that I was just
carrying it through into my life and it
was bleeding into my actual life I
didn't want to be it's exhausting being
an [ __ ] all the time I'm telling you
so I was like I don't want to do that I
just want to be me and have fun with
movies that are fun and [ __ ] on movies
that are [ __ ] and and that'll what we'll
go we'll see how it goes
we'll just say it how it is and it's
more enjoyable for me it seems to be
more enjoyable for you so I'm glad we're
all having a good time who's more badass
Batman or Thor
well Batman's the most badass of bad as
Iliad Thor can do you can call lightning
and he is badass but there's something
more badass about a guy who doesn't have
powers I know it's I mean people always
say that [ __ ] but there really is
something awesome about a guy who has no
powers who has the coolest villains and
comic books
Batman is pretty badass congratulations
Jeremy smiley face okay so what did you
major in I assume you're talking about
college here it is I'm going to college
I never went to college are you kidding
me going into debt to the point of
suicide never a thing I wanted to do I
remember in high school they were like
what are you good at I'm like I'm good
at talking and I liked movies what on
earth is there for me to do I think be
substitute teacher was one of the
careers on career day you take this test
and like you'll be good at I think it
was working with disabled kids honestly
as a substitute teacher [ __ ] so I was
corrected credit to people who do that
job that is taxing I couldn't do that
though
so obviously automatically I was like
that test knows nothing about me because
it's wrong so I just I was holding out
for that dare to be great situation as I
was a projection is for many years until
YouTube came around and I was like hey
I'll do that what are some of your
favorite movies that you haven't talked
about and do you plan on talking about
them and some other classics in the
future speaking of the future Back to
the Future Back to the Future in Indiana
Jones or like the quintessential
classics that I haven't talked about
that I really should talk about
hey Jeremy dude love your videos my
question is if you can hang out with any
three people they can either be dead or
alive who would they be in why that's
actually a really good question if I
could hang out with anyone throughout
history dead or alive whoever I would
hang out with Jesus Christ Buddha and
Muhammad and we would all hang out and
we'd have a good time and when we did I
would film myself and put this on
YouTube going hey guys we are all these
three are civilly hanging out and we're
enjoying each other's company so I'm
pretty sure if they can do that the
followers of them can do that too um and
that's who I'd hang out with and why
Howard gypsy in danger doing and can we
see them Lalo smileyface
gypsy in danger my dogs if you guys
didn't know I mean named them yes that's
after Pacific Rim yeah let's go see what
they're doing
all right we're alone in my living room
among all right my really cool nerdy
stuff right up there but that's not why
we're here we're here for gypsy in
danger so there's danger on the couch
looking at me like I'm out of my mind
and here is the Gypsy the gypsy gypsy no
dangerous like wait what's this madness
whoa danger you're way too close buddy
yeah they're good dogs there are little
mini Aussie shepherds this is danger
with a little skunk stripe on his head
and
[ __ ] danger is all about the fetch he
gypsy doesn't give a [ __ ]
danger big-time fetch dog so yes as I
sit down and bid you my farewell I'll
there were a lot of questions I didn't
expect the video to take this long let
alone realize that I was halfway through
the questions so I will do another Q&A
video get that to you hopefully sooner
than a month but this is just the first
half there's another wave of questions
coming these guys are just devouring my
arm a high danger he's like now I want
to be part of YouTube so yeah I'll get
that to you guys so thank you for half a
million subscribers well now it's like
half a million and a quarter of a
hundred thousand but I appreciate
everything and [ __ ] and danger has one
thing to say which is danger if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more